γιατρετ είναι ο κάρκιμος είναι τα κύρα τα οποία δεν σφέγονται τους κανώνες του οργανισμό
μας για να δημουργηθεί μια κακοησία σημαίνει ότι το ανοσωπιτικώ βασύστημα κάπου απαιτυχα θάσατε και
τη συζηγόσας τεαλάθο ναι την έχασα από κακοήθεια αυτό εναι η διαίτερας κληρών κάθε καρκίνος
είναι διαφορετικώς σε κάτε άτομο διαφορετικώς και χρειάζεται διαφορετική και προσωπική προσαγκιση ένας από τους
ασθενή σαεανοστέλειος κασανζίδης ι συζητήσεις μας ήταν περισότερο στης στην αδικεία που εσεν ο ίδιος
στη ζωή του γερμανικό γιατρικό κέντρο γαμλιστα πως προήκεψη πρόκυψε από μια ανάγκη την οποία
έβλεπα να υπάρχει η αυτό λογή μεταπόσχευψη γίνεται πρόλπου δεν υπάρχει νομοθησία γιαν δεν το
εκάμνα με ν εμείς και το έκομε κάποιος άλλος θέταν πιο εύκολα τα πράγματαδλευε φίλι
άλλο έναντε έναλλά υπότκα σήμερα μαζί σας ιδιαίτερη τημικαι χαρά φου μαζί μου είναι ένα
σκορυφέος επιστήμονας ένα ονόμα που έχει τη δική του ιστορία είναι ο γιατρός ον ικόλας
στος ζάμπογλου διευθύνων σύμβουλος του γερμανικού γιατρικού ιστητούτου μαζί θα δούμε διάφορα θέματα που σίγουρα
διαφέρουν όλους για τρέ χαριστό πολύπ αποδεχθηκάτε την πρόσκληση χαράμου ευχαριστόκυρό τιμήμε πομαζί σας δική
μα στιμή θέλο να ξεκινήσουμε λίγο γιατρετείναι ο καρκιος ο καρκίνος ουσιαστικά είναι τα κύτρα
τα ανεξέλεκτα τα οποία όπως τ αναφέρουμε και σαν κακοήθεια δε